this year the mvp odds are down two
patrick mahomes and aaron rodgers points
bet currently has patrick holmes
at minus 225 that's down slightly
from what it was just a day ago aaron
rodgers
plus 170 it's a two-man race
peter who between those two do you have
the most faith in right now
you know look if i had to if i had to
pick one right now i'd probably pick
rogers
but there is an absolute hair between
the two of them and that is it
yeah it depends on the last three weeks
that's one of the reasons why i say all
the time look
we can say who's ahead right now but if
just because i say aaron rodgers
is a nif just a a centimeter ahead right
now
in my mind i don't think that really
means very much because there's three
games left
to play and if mahom if mahomes goes
into new orleans
and blows out new orleans then
all of a sudden again almost for about
the fifth time this year
you change your mind about who's at the
top yeah i i'm with you peter i i would
give the
i mean i would give the edge to aaron
rodgers right now as well
i i mean mahomes is amazing you know but
i guess if you made me bet who i think's
gonna win
i you know i think the voters are going
to vote for mahomes but that would not
be where my vote's going to go
it's not for what rogers is doing for
that football team
you know hey yeah it's a solid defense
all right aaron jones was hurt for a
number of games this year he's just
getting
back in the swing we had a number of
games where we were like who
who you know again who the hell's
playing receiver for green bay
like who is this guy oh okay yeah i mean
just the fact
that everything really runs through
rogers
uh and the fact that he doesn't have a
tyree kill and a kelsey and a sami
watkins
and a guy that like andy reed around him
i would give him the advantage but
peter's right
i mean yeah mahomes on the 425 national
stage
this week if he goes and tears up the
saints that's going to change a lot of
people's
opinions i will say this i think rogers
has an easier path here right now
because of the defenses he has to play
mahomes
you know dealing with the saints this
week dealing with he's going to have to
deal with the chargers maybe the last
week of the year
and even the falcons who we've seen
those are two defensive schemes too that
have given
mahomes issues to where it could lead to
some underwhelming numbers i don't know
either way i mean it's it's awesome
versus awesome it's it's just
it's fun to watch and it's no two guys
i'd rather talk about
yeah and even those two have clearly
separated from the pack there was one
guy that we talked about earlier this
week and apparently
the bettors out there have taken notice
either with our influence or on their
own because derek henry the titans
running back has fallen from plus ten
thousand meaning you bet a hundred you
win 10
000 down to plus 6600 people are betting
on derrick henry and changing the odds
dramatically
because peter derrick kennedy's got 1532
rushing yards after 2 15 on sunday
against the jaguars
averaging 191 a week which is a tall
tall order
and there's one guy in the nfl who can
do it and his name is derek henry
he could set the single season rushing
record and if he does that
how does he not get votes for mvp
because the mvp is a
weird chameleon of an award
i remember back i think it was 2012
when adrian peterson won it and i think
he won it because of some
emotion because remember the end of the
previous year he's laying there with an
acl tear
and he comes back and he is better than
ever he says i'm going to be better than
ever and he wins the rushing title
and i think it was in part an emotional
thing for this
incredible accomplishment for adrian
peterson
now having said that to me i
and look if if derek henry does that
then that throws a major monkey wrench
into the situation but
i mean look if there's a lot of things
you could say if so and so
averages whatever if mahomes averages
425 passing yards a game the rest of the
way
then he's gonna do so ever i i don't
even know what it is
but what i'm saying is that i think in
terms of value the only way
that derrick henry with a team that has
more losses than either of the other two
contenders and one of them by far i
i think it's going to be hard plus you
know look for half of this season
if you gave somebody an mvp vote in
tennessee
probably six or seven games you would
have given it probably to ryan tannehill
so you know look i i and and it could be
derek henry who knows
three weeks from now i might be voting
for derek henry but
as of now he would not be uh in
in the same uh discussion as those other
two
mike i mean
there's a chance he gets can get to
2000. we talked a little yesterday the
defenses he's playing
are crapola as far as the run is
concerned
it's crap hola you got the lions and
then the texans
i mean you saw the texans last week they
made the bears look like they were the
greatest show on turf
all right he if they're still playing
for something that week he might run for
400 yards in that game
i mean i'm joking but with the defenses
he has
up up in front of him i think he can
make a play for it but mike ultimately i
think
like something you've said really
through the last four or five weeks
about this race
you know if they were flirting with the
number one seed
i think then it'd be legitimate like
where you'd really go okay
but you know we hold the quarterbacks to
that type of standard
and okay well you know the the offense
the team runs through derrick henry
there in
nashville with the tennessee titans
that's great but
i think to peter's point you know they
have as many losses as the packers and
chiefs combined
and that i think ultimately holds him
back the question i pose for you guys
all right just
because i think we're done a little does
he automatically win offensive player of
the year
if he gets close to 2 000 in a year like
this with some of the guys like with
travis kelsey and tyree killed all these
touchdowns and what they're doing does
he automatically get that if he doesn't
you know get the mvp
peter isn't that the compromise vote
isn't that how it goes if one
if there's a quarterback who's mvp then
the guy who's done the
impressive statistical thing 2000
rushing yards he becomes the offensive
player of the year
yeah i mean look i i've always done it
that i'm going to pick the guy who had
the best offensive
season okay look if derek henry has 2
100 yard rushing yards i'm probably
going to vote for derek henry
if you know pick a receiver justin
jefferson has
you know whatever 1500 1800 yards and
and 16 touchdowns well i'm probably
going to vote for him
but i do think that that
is speaking of the chameleon award that
is the one where from year to year you
have no idea
how voters vote and i always try to say
what offensive player had the best
season right you know regardless if if
it's some if it's some tackle
who gives up zero sacks has zero
penalties
uh and and you know he's proclaimed as
you know uh the greatest since munoz i'd
consider voting for him
but usually it's the guy who has the
starriest season
with numbers wha what i'm just laying
out scenarios here because i think it's
very possible
all right with derek henry i mean i
peter i agree with everything you
said i mean you're right what if derek
henry gets to like
1950 right somewhere in 1900
unbelievable season i mean it just it
pops at you
but what if travis kelsey leads the nfl
in receiving yards and everything like
that we've never seen a tight end do
that
i mean that to me and then what if tyree
killed
who's leading the nfl in touchdown
receptions has another few to add on
here
to me that's where it could be actually
one of the more intriguing
offensive player of the year
conversations here the way it's setting
up with some of these guys
i think travis kelsey that's a fantastic
point
if he does something that's never been
done right uh
and and you know we'd have to i i would
have to also
look at at at every number not just one
number but
if he does something that's never been
done that would weigh heavily on my vote
there's been no tight end that's ever
led the league in receiving yards
there's been no tight end that's ever
been offensive player of the year
there's been two receivers jerry rice
won it twice and michael thomas last
year
all of the other years it's been a
quarterback or a running back
who should be the favorite right now for
most receiving yards we've got
kelsey at 1250 dk metcas 1180
stefan diggs 1167 tyree kill 1158
deandre hopkins 1155 they are bunched
together
travis kelsey is the favorite at plus
225 who do you think gets it
i think kelsey gets it because i think
that
first of all um andy reid
knows that i i and
kelsey's probably not gonna say this
means a lot to him this means a lot to
him
andy reid knows that and i think andy
reid will do a lot to try to make this
happen
and and look especially if kansas city
is going to win the one seed if kansas
city does and
look you have to say that if they go to
new orleans this weekend
and and win that game you know they're
pretty
and they're not a lock but they're very
very close to winning the one seed
so if they get there the
a lot of people might say well take your
veterans in week 17 and give them a
light workload
i don't know that andy reid is going to
do that he might do it with some
especially some guys who really need the
rest
but if there's nothing physically wrong
with travis kelsey
other than the normal bumps and bruises
i think he tries to help travis kelsey
because look put yourself in the place
of a kansas city offensive player and
look
they are a great all for one one for
all team but in reality isn't this all
for
one one for mahomes i mean
you know everything is a headline about
patrick mahomes
and don't you think that it would be a
great thing for travis kelsey
if if he does or tyree kill quite
honestly
to win offensive player of the year that
would be the sort of spreading of the
wealth that in my opinion
kind of reading andy reid i think that's
how he would feel yeah
i mean i i agree with you there and you
know i mean that that's you know tyree
kill that's the other one we can't leave
out of this conversation
you know the touchdowns the big plays
the things he does for that
yeah might not be 140 receptions and
those type of things
but when he touches the ball it changes
the football game
and when he touches the ball it's like a
touchdown every third time he does it so
it's just
it's amazing from that aspect i mean
from the receiving yards thing
you know i don't know who wins but i'm
going with one of the guys in kansas
city all right it's one of those two
freak shows i know that
because when you got when you're a freak
show at tight end and a freak show at
receiver
and then you got maybe one of the
greatest freak shows ever throwing you
the football
uh my money is on one of those two guys
and i don't know who that'll be
i don't uh both are phenomenal but like
you know dk metcalf that conversation
you know they got they played too many
good defenses down the stretch here for
me to jump into that they got washington
the 49ers the rams again i haven't have
a hard time thinking he goes off
you know stefan diggs is awesome as he's
in he's got the patriots and dolphins on
the horizon
i don't think he goes off on that so
that's why i go like
i'm with you peter i think it's the
kansas city guys it's one of those two
uh because they're both special and
doing things that you just don't see on
an every season type basis
and chris just so we're clear on this
when you call those guys freak shows you
mean it in a respectful oh the most
respectful way you can when i'm talking
freak shows i mean you are awesome and i
wish
i could be a freak show like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports